Sometimes, seeing the trailers for upcoming
features can be the best part of going to
the theater.
But as we all know, the final product can
be very different from the way it's portrayed
in the promo clips—in fact, sometimes, trailers
flat out lie to us.
Here are some of the worst offenders.
Snow Dogs
It sure looks like it has all the hallmarks
of a classic live-action talking animal movie:
it's made by Disney, shares a producer with
George of the Jungle and Charlotte's Web,
and the trailer even ends with a clip of wisecracking
dogs.
But viewers expecting 2002's Snow Dogs to
be a raucous fish-out-of-water story with
funny canines and copious pratfalls were given…
well, pretty much that, only without any talking
animals.
Anyone expecting Air Bud went home disappointed,
as the scene where the dogs mock Cuba Gooding
Jr.'s character is actually from a dream sequence.
"You really stepped in it this time!"
Kangaroo Jack
The blatantly misleading trailer for Snow
Dogs was a direct inspiration for Kangaroo
Jack's infamously misleading marketing, according
to the Los Angeles Times.
Inspired by the earlier film, producer Jerry
Bruckheimer made Jack look less like a dark
mafia comedy and more like a light family
friendly romp focused on kangaroo-related
hijinx.
"I said a hip, hop, beh hibbie, to the hip
hip hop and you don't stop the rock to the
bang bang boogie."
Like Snow Dogs, the talking animal scene is
just a dream, but the trailer doesn't make
that clear.
A rapping kangaroo, combined with repeated
shots of the lead characters screaming and
pratfalling, helped to convince parents that
the movie was goofy family-friendly fare.
Instead, thousands of kids found some surprisingly
lewd humor and a baffling plot about adult
friendships and failed dreams.
Sweeney Todd: The Demon Barber of Fleet Street
Yes, it's been musical on Broadway for decades,
but the trailer for Tim Burton's Sweeney Todd:
The Demon Barber of Fleet Street does everything
it can to hide that fact.
A clip of Johnny Depp talk-singing is buried
within a preview that makes the gothic musical
look more like a combination of Dexter, The
Count of Monte Cristo, and an action thriller.
Why the trailer does everything it can to
hide its musical roots is anyone's guess,
especially when it looks identical to every
other Tim Burton movie without it.
Observe and Report
An unrelenting, in-depth examination of a
profoundly disturbed individual, 2009's Observe
and Report is like Taxi Driver filtered through
the madcap antics of Seth Rogen's everyman
comedy stylings.
But you'd be hard-pressed to tell by watching
the trailer, which makes it look like a stealth
sequel to Paul Blart: Mall Cop—or at least
a rated-R parody of it.
The clip looks like it's advertising yet another
story of a schlubby guy in a crummy job finding
worth and acceptance in proving himself a
hero, but the actual plot of the movie is
closer to the drug-filled last days of a genuine
psychopath.
Godzilla
2014 was a mourning period for fans of Walter
White's misadventures on the popular TV show
Breaking Bad—it had been off for a year
by that point, and fans were missing Bryan
Cranston's nuanced portrayal of a beleaguered
family man making huge sacrifices for the
ones he loves.
But then the trailer for Godzilla arrived,
showcasing Cranston once again as a beleaguered
family man, this time struggling to stop the
famous monster.
Unfortunately, the trailer was clearly cut
once the marketing team realized how popular
Cranston had become.
He's only in the movie for just more than
a quarter of the runtime — a major bait-and-switch.
Ravenous
Going by the trailer, 1999's Ravenous looks
like a screwball comedy, or a Troma film that
was stuck in the vault for 20 years.
What audiences missed out on was an audacious
horror-comedy, with a remarkable performance
by Guy Pearce.
The movie's take on cannibalism deserves to
go down as a formative horror text, but it's
hard to convince anyone to watch after they've
seen the trailer.
On the bright side, unlike many of the other
movies on this list, the only lie this trailer
is telling is that the movie isn't fantastic.
Drive
Director Nicolas Refn's Drive is a slow, thorough
examination of crime and career criminals,
wrapped in layers of allegory and striking
cinematography.
Which is why it's so ridiculous that the trailer
makes it look like a Fast and the Furious
flick, all pulse-pounding chase sequences
and fight scenes.
The marketing was so misleading that one woman
even sued the distributor, complaining that
the movie had "very little driving."
All that's missing is Vin Diesel shouting
about "family."
"There's always room for family."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!